[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with somebody interesting from the
internet and this week that person who
will be sitting down at the round table
of dim lighting is Justine ezarik better
known as iJustine who I think is one of
the first ever major female internet
celebrities period right internets
celebrities in general I mean this girl
as far back as we can remember we were
starting out on the internet back in oh
six we knew about her right from the
very beginning oh yeah she was she was
in the middle of it now I I don't know
if the lifecasting came first or if I
think we met her after lifecasting but I
definitely knew about it when it was
happening when she was broadcasting
every moment of her life not just waking
moment every single moment sleeping or
waking 24/7 for six months straight on
justin.tv right I mean that was an
amazing thing that we talked to her
about and of course she also made a lot
of youtube videos many of which got
traction early on in the age of YouTube
publishing a vlog about her iPhone bill
that was 300 pages long it came in a box
yeah this is a true story right after
iPhone the iPhone came out and it was
they were printing these huge bills and
she just made all these calls that was
her first real viral video and you know
she's built this huge audience on
YouTube she's got a number of channels
collectively about three million
subscribers but you know I follow her on
Instagram and Twitter and I am
constantly just seeing she's somewhere
else in the world and sometimes I'm just
what cut my TV on and she's on the TV
hosting something she's you know she's
on a red carpet somewhere she's hosting
something for call of duty she's on
she's making an appearance on Law &
Order or something like that so yeah you
know you she's everywhere or on her
YouTube channel vlogging from Iceland
most recently she was a she made a cameo
in our I'm at expert rap music video she
also made a cameo way back in the day
one of our early music videos I think it
was Oh 8 the dead iPod song she
basically is the the she opens that
whole video up that's right clap I think
our very first collaboration was with
Justine and the first time we ever
collaborated before anybody called it a
collaboration we just said we're just
gonna work with you on this you don't
think the word collaboration was used
everybody talks about oh who you
collabing with now I mean we didn't they
didn't talk about collapse we were just
like yeah you want to be in our video
we'll give use you'll get views it'll be
great we actually released the video on
her channel in our channel on the same
day trying to figure out what was the
best way to go about this thing but I
mean when she was on the text bird thing
to Tex Bert's shoot it was basically the
next day or two she was she was off to
Iceland in writing so to your point
she's always somewhere we talked to her
about that just about what her life is
like now I mean not only being she's not
a life caster anymore but so much of her
life is still online in terms of all the
contents she's creating all over the
place all over the world right so we go
back to the beginning what it's like to
be raised as a literal Coal Miner's
Daughter in Pennsylvania what it was
like to do that live casting life
casting for six months we get into
talking about some old boyfriends and
some current boyfriend's boyfriend
singular she says she has one boyfriend
now and Ryan's also an online
personality so that I mean there's
there's an issue a fascinating dynamic
there where they draw the line between
their their personal relationship and
their their public personas and just her
public and private persona between
Justin and iJustine and we talk about
what it's like to still be in this
YouTube game after eight years on the
platform so here it is our ear biscuit
with Justine
[Music]
really because you hit reward
this is video answered there was that
pregnant pause so I guess let's get
right to it so you're pregnant let's get
right to it
no I'm not actually I I'm sure that
every type of rumor goes around Twitter
base about you like have you had a
actually I'm just assuming has there
been a pregnancy rumor yes because
that's like the height of celebrity
right usually there was and was my own
fault because I was taking a picture
looking down really sad at my phone
because it was broken but I had my leg
up and so it looked like it was a part
of my shirt so everyone's like oh my god
she's definitely pregnant what was it
like what was a part of your shirt um
with foam I know my pants because I was
like kneeling and I was I was just being
really sad about my phone and and it
just looked like I was pregnant and I
wasn't I'm not did you feel the need to
clarify or did oh yeah even my sister's
like oh my god I can't believe you
posted that you look pregnant I was like
I didn't know I just was really sad my
phone wasn't working were you holding a
pregnancy test
unless there's an app for that but it
probably is oh don't pee on your iPhone
you done that mm-hmm how else do you
clean it I don't know but the people the
Apple stores they know because they have
taken them apart and found little poo
traces and when you try to tell them no
I didn't drop it in the toilet they know
because they can see the poo yeah toilet
I have not but well interestingly though
you recently dropped the phone into like
a Blue Lagoon in Iceland I did do that
and then a week later I shattered the
phone that I had just bought in the
subway in New York so it was really fun
how did that happen I had a suitcase and
we were doing the scene where I was
walking down to the subway and I didn't
realize that my phone was on top of the
suitcase and I also had nothing in the
suitcase so I was being an idiot and was
like look how light my suitcase is it
was a prop he basically yeah so but the
phone was not the prop it was on there
and it went flying
like 20 feet and just flew down and just
shattered how many phones have you been
through a lot just get I mean give me a
ballpark I don't I don't know I mean I
can't count because I think it's an
uncountable number now I mean I've had
I've definitely had one of each phone
that has come out and then a couple of
each so so so there's always there's
with each model I can that would be ten
well it's definitely more than that
really I've definitely yeah I've had
some problems and you kill all of them
you don't know until recently I done
really well until this one this is
stupid gold phone man but when you were
an I I want to go back to Iceland
because I really enjoyed those videos I
mean made me want to go you sure really
want to go to I'm not going to let spin
still it goes with me you should have
put that in your contract but hey you
know I don't negotiate for you screen no
that was actually real but it was kind
of crazy cuz me my sister went and saw
the movie and when we left that theater
I was like we have to go to Iceland we
have to and then it just randomly
happened whenever the DVD release was
out Fox and emailed means like hey we
need somebody to go to Iceland for a
movie and I wrote back like all capital
letters I didn't know this dude I was
like is it The Secret Life of Walter
Mitty call me in how'd you tweet it or
in it made anything public that you were
a fan of the movie I did but I don't
think they even found it from there
which is weird so I don't know but you
were in this huge I mean we're like in
the snowy terrain with this if the hot
spring I mean when I think about hot
springs I think about something as big
as this dimly lit table like a hot tub I
don't think about a a large pond or a
small lake but that's what you were in
right yeah it was like this massive pond
and everyone's day me yeah it was so hot
it's like from like the lava rocks and
everything there is all geothermal so
right they they don't pay for heats
because it's all just natural but it's
so hot in there it's it's actually blue
like is really blue but it's all like
minerals so as soon as I dropped my
phone in which I had a lifeproof case on
so I don't know what happened I think it
might have been actually too hot the
minerals ate through the case or the
case does New York immediately recover
the phone or did it go - I you had to
search for it for a while no I had I
didn't drop it and I mean I just I was
just using it I'm gestured it into the
water
waterproof no you'd think it would be
why is there some sort of guarantee nope
and they wouldn't tweet me back so I
just unfollowed him on Twitter oh okay
so that's how you you went for it you
you you actually made it public you were
like hey I was here with your case and
it's it won't survive a Blue Lagoon it
won't but it did survive a shark dive so
I'll give him that was the bottom of the
lagoon like I don't know you couldn't
see it I think you all just sucks you
were treading water no you can stand up
good things I can't swim what did it
feel like it felt like rocks time out
you can swim not really I couldn't I'm
done gargling paddle you guys can't see
it well I'm teaching my five-year-old
son how to completely swim this summer
so if you want to come along for lessons
I'm really I'm really good okay this is
really this is working out really well I
feel like this would be a great series
suggesting learns to swim at age five
well okay then you're not gonna say your
age but let's wait until the second half
of the podcast to talk about everything
associated with your age but I think the
the Iceland Greenland Iceland what is
Iceland which is greener than ice
Greenland yes but we don't go there yes
it represents the justing us the
iJustine stereotype in my mind that
she's always somewhere it is true yeah
and we've tried just not show so many
times yeah I mean this is like I think
the fifth or sixth time I know but I
think it's just indicative of your life
because most most of the time if not
every single time that we've had you
booked for the show you've been asked to
then go do something that really you
know this ear biscuits come and go right
we do it every week but you had an
opportunity that you had to say yes to
so it seems like you're just kind of
constantly off in a way yeah it's
limited dream well it is but it's really
hard to plan anything and it's like I
mean I feel like I have no friends here
anymore because that no one even asks me
to hang out anymore because they're like
she's not here anyway and then I'm like
well quantify how much are you gone I
mean I was gone from was nine weeks and
that I was here for like a week
a few days in between but then I had
shoots every day so I couldn't do
anything else so it's like even like
doing YouTube videos I have to like
schedule a day that I can actually film
something for myself but thankfully like
traveling it's always good content it's
fun so I can still like post that kind
of stuff right so I mean if it's not
Iceland it could be Greenland or it's
Hawaii or I think oh ye is like always
your vacation go to it's a nice little
easy trip from from over here but what's
the is this the status of your
professional life that it's invitation
and invitation and there's other things
going on too but I'm curious if you're
gone that much it's there's kind of an
approach to life to make that happen cuz
people approach such late notice right
they do so I mean that's the thing is I
try not to plan things far in advance
and if it is that far in advance I mean
it has to be like okay look even my
family vacation I have to now go halfway
through the vacation because I have
something else that came up that's like
oh my god I can't not do this and inside
it's like my family's like what we want
to hang out with you're like yeah mom
but I have to do this like I can't not I
cord it's like Call of Duty is gonna be
the x-games it's the first time the Call
of Duty is gonna be on TV as like an
actual sport so like well it's an export
well you know like so it's an official
Call of Duty is an official x game X
Kate well at least in this this this
round in Austin we're just kind of cool
because it's like my favorite game so
it's gonna be on ESPN as a sport so it's
really fun and you'll be there in a in a
host capacity yeah because you've been
there for like the past how many
launches of the they had like a it's
like different tournaments and it's
crazy like these kids are playing call
of duty as a profession like we're
making YouTube videos that's a
profession like they're playing call of
duty and it's it's really cool cuz
that's an actual sport now so of you
you're obviously obviously saying yes to
a lot of things which means you're also
saying no to a lot of things but I mean
what is what is that like being
constantly asked to go do something as
opposed to maybe you know rewind five
years where you're just making content
yeah you know you're like thinking about
your own content and now you're being
tapped to go do all these different
things like yeah I mean it's definitely
fun but it's like I really miss doing
like this kind of stuff and just hanging
out and like making YouTube videos but I
feel like making YouTube videos now
isn't what it used to be necessarily
yeah I mean YouTube has changed so much
and and it's really hard to make that
consistent content and and it's it's so
hard because you could never make
everyone happy which is so hard for me
because I'm like man little Gianni 55
didn't like this video but he really
liked the last one I'm like sorry Johnny
what is it more specifically that you're
saying oh they didn't like this or
there's complaints or I mean I think
it's with anything what's the state of
YouTube and your YouTube account at this
point I think the good thing is I've
never committed to doing one of one
thing so no one really ever knows what
to expect so even when they say man we
really missed your older videos I'm like
well I'm still kind of doing the same
thing which is really just a bunch of
random stuff so I think the hard part
though is is trying to find the time to
edit
I mean traveling and editing on the
plane it's like okay I know my battery
will last for three hours or an hour and
a half if I'm actually encoding and
rendering so I think that's that's the
hard thing now you and I know a lot of
people have editors but for me like my
content is so personal to me and to my
audience that like no one can ever just
edit it just right how I would even
though it's not like these intense crazy
edits it's like I want it to be like I
want it to be like I did it
have you had editors work for you and
and you said you know what this is just
not working because of that lack of the
personal connection I mean I've had some
people edits and things in my car did
you do this and then I'm like well here
why don't you do this or this or this
and then I'm at that point I why don't I
just do it myself and it's already done
I mean what's interesting is my sister
Jenna she's actually becoming quite the
little editor and she gets my sense of
humor so you're gonna hire her you know
feed her and like buy her video games
you'll enslave her okay well did you
work in the coal mines no I didn't and
that would sound like there's people
thinking whoa that sounds I don't know
what what the coal miner version
of the stereotype is but when you're in
Pittsburgh your dad's a coal miner he's
retired that's a founded the question is
founded in reality yes it's not like an
insult like his dad was a coal miner
like it's just that's what you did
you're literally a Coal Miner's Daughter
yeah that's did you grow up so you
weren't in the coal mine as a ten year
old know which red is saying would be
legal but wasn't the type of thing that
what did your dad do specifically you
say he's retired now did he come home
with like soot all over his face I think
they showered before they came home but
yeah like he would walk the mines and
then I'm not actually sure what he
really did but he worked like seven days
a week which when we were younger that's
every day yeah of the week and we didn't
really realize that that's not really
that like normal like most people don't
really work seven days a week
and my mom's a gym teacher so she worked
you know five days a week and then would
have summers off it was like up my dad
works Midnight's tonight so the famous
thing I think there's actually a game
called that it was like I was like she
don't wake daddy like that was not a
game it's like someone board game yeah
it's like a board game so that was like
basically our child was like Shh quiet
but you had to roll out his appendix
without making the buzzer sound because
that wake him up that's operation yeah
something like that so he worked nights
seven nights a week he would switch off
like back and forth so sometimes he
would work at night or he would
recurring the day so I can't even
imagine having that type of schedule
it's crazy
so did you you never saw him I guess we
did randomly yeah but it would be but he
was always sleeping a lot was retired
now yeah yes so you still found time how
he's still like coached all of our
softball games and was okay so he was
he's very present yes he was pride is
really tired was it did he have like a
pick are you thinking like minecraft now
I don't think you like really like went
down and like was it's more so he's like
a supervisor
he was like a point [ __ ] more of a
pointer or a picker I don't know but I
don't think there was any pics involved
Oh heavy machinery probably a lot of
walking in them I don't know this is not
some really great question you never got
to take a tour no but I did go in some
mine but that wasn't actually the one
that you actually go in it was like some
tourist mine
it had like lights and it looked on nice
and fancy and they would give you some
cool candy when you walked out was your
dad there I think just like some
tourists you know your dad need to
reconnect Father's Day is coming up
maybe you don't need to skip out on this
family vacation I was a lot of coal
mining to discuss we do this is great
I'm gonna start taking some notes and
your family vacation is in North
Carolina right that's where you go every
year
go to the Outer Banks share place and
then you go to the Harris Teeter and you
make a music video I sold never boasted
the one from last year oh really
yeah sure probably that did that it's
sitting in a folder on my desktop and I
look at it every day every day for a
year pretty once and your mom was a gym
teacher you say yeah she still is and
sometimes all good Instagram comments or
YouTube they're like hey your mom's my
gym teacher like hey how's it going so
does she wear like softball pants what
kind of gym tees are we talking about
what kind of pants is your mom okay
she's very specific about her pants she
loves like the swishy pants and they
have to be have like an elastic band and
they have to have pockets trust me we've
shopped and it's very hard to find those
for most pants like warm-up pants and
jacket are they tapered on the bottom
mm no just like nice and like a lot
flared but enough that like you can wear
your are they rip away no that could be
but it's not a professional basketball
player or a stripper well I had I mean I
had a pair rip away pants just cuz I
mean I odd putting out while I was
playing basketball this is post
basketball I had some too I mean those
are things are great now that the
ripping away is exciting
there was a ping the buttoning back up
it's like well how did I rip these away
yeah it's like got to rebuild pants now
yeah you gotta count cost yeah you gotta
count the cost of something like so what
grades does she teach Jim to pick 7th
and 8th oh wow middle school gym
does she like what did they do dodgeball
now or though no they still do yeah you
can still do that in Pennsylvania she
did they had a she taught them to do
juggling which was I don't remember I
was probably I was pretty young Alfredo
sixth seventh eighth grade but then I
learned to juggle so I can still to this
day juggle which is very exciting it's a
nice little parlor trick
pull that when you're in the parlor so
you did a little bit of jug on me that
wasn't your thing no I loved taking
stuff apart like that was like I would
take apart VCRs and that was really
really well I love like technology and I
can never put it back together so my dad
would end up having to like fix what
everything because that sounded I say
really because that sounds like a
convenient iJustine back story okay any
further do you guys remember when I had
you on my podcast
actually no you don't oh you got a
refresh my memory my gosh okay I think
it's actually still online somewhere
we're just kind of embarrassing cuz I
don't know remotely yeah yeah had it
been oh it was so long ago um I think it
was called mommy packed my lunch here
yeah that was your blog was named that
alright and then that was like me and me
and my friend Desiree we made we did a
podcast and I remember having you guys
on it what year do you think this was
2007 or seven I've I was still in
Pittsburgh and had no idea that I was
ever gonna leave so this I think was
early it was revered days oh definitely
revered days oh six okay $20.00 I'm so
pissed so we need to explain revver is a
was an early competitor to YouTube I
don't even think we're even a competitor
well it did the same thing except you
got you supposedly you got paid four
views back before YouTube Partner
Program before they would pay you four
views so there was a I remember we made
a conscious choice to put our videos on
revver and we didn't really worry about
YouTube because they had a there was a
revenue model there that we could
potentially make some money and I think
that that's how we met each other right
was we were both being featured on
revver
and son I think somehow the
we like emailed or something I can't
remember the specifics but there was an
email exchange which evidently led to I
guess being guest on your podcast is
Ellie I don't recall because I actually
don't remember but I know I was like
Tess you're never gonna believe this
podcast she definitely supported all of
these random endeavors but was just like
okay like she was crazy like me but then
she yeah I remember I remember her and I
remember so you guys were friends and
what that was like high school it was in
college and college yeah okay and then
you were doing a you guys were doing a
myspace thing too right oh yeah oh my
gosh I completely forgot about cuz I
think it I remember like if he went to
your MySpace page I think it was like
Justine and Desiree right you guys were
like almost like a duo mm-hmm that's how
you were presenting yourself on on
MySpace yeah I think well I mean I had
like my own myspace and then we had like
doesn't Justine and then our I don't
know weren't even came from it was like
mommy packed my lunch that was like our
like website together cuz I don't even
know why we liked sandwiches and paper
bags and we liked lunch so and mommy's
yeah so I'm not sure where that came
from but yeah you guys were on it we're
gonna have to look that up okay okay so
you were fixing VCRs you're you were you
were being the second part breaking them
actually you were being geeky not
because it would be a great back story
later but because you were actually
interested I mean as a as a young girl
yeah I just I just really didn't really
know what else to do and I was bored and
there was really nothing else to do cuz
I grew up in the middle of nowhere I
mean honestly like Kyle's outside the
past jerilyn okay I don't really like
going outside how far outside of
Pittsburgh are we talking about was like
in about an hour outside of Pittsburgh
yeah but um yeah cows and stuff and VCRs
and I will never forget though like my
sister got a guinea pig and that was
like the star of all of the videos that
I would make this poor little thing and
same with squeaky it ended up dying to
this squeak it did you would lift it up
and you just like shake it a little bit
and he would he would talk like a Furby
you know I know yeah yeah he was he's
really cute and he like a perishable
Furby
and he ended up dying cuz he had a
tennis ball size tumor on the side of
his little butt Guinea tumors are the
worst when he was so cute but he was in
many movies but I filmed on a massive
VCR like camcorder oh wow so you were
still using that I mean this was I was
probably sixth grade okay and usually
oldest child mm-hmm
so does that mean that you were kind of
I'm in charge here I'm like because you
had two younger sisters yeah I think I
was uh mm-hmm I would make them do
whatever I wanted and I would beat them
up until they became bigger and stronger
than me and then they beat me up and
then I stopped but you made the decision
to include the guinea pig as the star
not your little sisters they were kind
of young men but I mean the guinea pig
was just there and it just was a better
actress and you didn't turn the camera
on yourself because no one did that no I
did some it was too heavy to hold it
that's internet on yourself right I
think it would tripod but I think he's
just like set it on the table yeah
people do stupid things but yeah it's
like I've been doing that forever so you
can just change your parents still have
drawers of these guinea pig videos and
your earliest deviations do yeah there's
some where those have to be found but
you have not found or digitized any of
this some good stuff okay you should
also do that while talking to your dad
about coal mining dad that's your
project I'll do that in family vacation
so when you were making the guinea pig
videos did you think this is what I want
to do when I grow up type thing or is it
just a kid having fun you got a camera
and you've got a guinea pig you know let
the fun ensue yeah I think I was just
having fun and a lot of this too even
how I started doing this is I can't
remember anything like I have the worst
memory ever so I started filming like
vlogs and just videos before they're
even called vlogs just because like oh
this is a fun thing I'd like to remember
it and like it what what point are we
talking about are we talking in college
you started filming forward so I think
that would be but even in high school I
mean I was taking photos I had like a
daily random photo site so I would just
post a photo every day this was still
HTML like I was Co
the forward in the back page and
creating each separate thing so there
was nothing at that time that you could
even do that with so I just did it
myself and it was kind of a it was a
personal project website or were there
like your friends were looking at this I
mean like my friends were looking at it
so I get like 100 views or something
wrong from like around and somehow it
was found on the internet but it was
just more for fun so that I would
remember things that we would do so what
what else did you do like what was the
high school Justine like she was really
cool she was had like so many friends
did she have lots of boyfriends how did
that work
were you like I always have a boyfriend
or I have one boyfriend for a really
long time I did have one for a very long
time was his name Josh Josh what's Josh
doing now he's actually he's now married
um I haven't talked to him in a while
but he's a great guy very very nice high
school boyfriend long-term friend how
long did you date Josh oh man this was
jeez I don't know I don't remember it
was a while and then we broke up and
then we started dating again and then Oh
see you broke up broke is on again off
again or a big breakup and then most
through most of most of high school and
then I think oh did you go to did you go
to college together no no he was
actually two or three years older than
me oh wow yeah you know older guy I
think it was my because I went to one
prom and then my actual junior prom is
when I went to a LAN party with Josh no
he wasn't there he was off in college
that he was off in college being you
know like an older man so what you
wanted to go to a LAN party or you
didn't want to go to the prom with
anybody but Josh I didn't like dances or
any of that stuff so I mean I went to
the one prom with him just cuz I was
like all right well I guess their
girlfriends dance here but it was fun
but I definitely had more fun to LAN
party playing video games and
drinking Mountain Dew okay has you do it
Alan what does that mean you had a lot
of guy friends too I think I'm not
really sure if I actually had any
friends I don't really remember I mean I
think I had friends but it was just it's
not like you keep in touch with these
people for Josh but I do still randomly
talk to people on Facebook and stuff
like that but yeah let's keep talking
about Josh yes like a muffin Lissa let's
call him right now I probably would so
you broke up yeah you broke up he was so
you he was like what's he in college
somewhere and you were in high school
and you guys are still dating looks like
number we have nothing you want to call
him right now
number I just wanted to see if it
actually turned to iMessage or not and
it did I mean I mean he's got a wife
it's not really appropriate it would
stir up you know what first of all I'm
gonna go and tell you right now
his wife already knows about you and in
it is like yeah my husband used to date
that girl that's everywhere on the
Internet they probably might have a
great marriage but I'm just saying I'm
telling you not from experience but just
maybe from stories that I've heard the
craziest thing that was like seeing your
a source of strife in their marriage
like seeing his his brothers kids like
that we used to babysit and they were
like just very small children and now
they're like graduating the high school
that I went to and I'm like oh my gosh
this is crazy
like this is insane they're your fans I
haven't talked to them since they were
like - I know I'm just I I'm not
intentionally making this weird
I'm just very much fascinated about this
Josh character because I mean you dated
him for your whole high school and then
into your college and then oh that must
have been a big break so there is you
know his college yeah there was a there
was a big breakup and but then you got
back together why'd you do that
just really really nice I just think I'm
just so indecisive but that's really the
problem I think in most of my
relationships it's like I don't really
know what I want I don't really know
what I'm doing but whatever I'm doing I
don't think this is it I mean this is
maybe a little out of order here but not
out of line just out of chronological
order you're in a relationship now
that's been going for a couple years
we're actually trying to figure that out
this morning to be honest with you
trying to figure out how long you been
dating within two years well I mean I
have notes here you know I can tell you
that you've been dating Ryan Wyatt
VP of programming at major league gaming
used to be a head of live in eSports and
machinima he'd been dating him since
2012 we do research I don't know the
date she was like before a Call of Duty
came out remember work I need to do my
owners so did Josh introduce you to Ryan
Oh actually Ryan at UH we did a Call of
Duty show he was my coach for my team I
played against Michelle Rodriguez and my
team won really yeah although I went
around and found the best Call of Duty
players I knew to be on my team so
obviously we were gonna win and then you
get you started dating we dead over two
years ago yeah I guess that's what it
looks like I should probably let him
know that's not indecisive I mean this
is a this is a relatively long-term
relationship you know relationships
lasted for a while and it's like I'm on
say like everything's going great and
it's so weird because we actually don't
really ever fight like we get along
great do you ever see each other that's
yeah but you're I mean but you have been
gone for nine weeks and he's you know I
follow him on Instagram he's always he's
always got one of those headsets on and
he saw he's always announcing something
something that's true yeah he's like a
he's like a sports anchor sportscaster
for call duty yeah so I mean it's cool
cuz we get to go to a lot of the same
events and stuff together so that's
always really fun too cuz I mean
we travel a lot but yet a lot of the
stuff that we're traveling for we're
doing the same thing so it's really fun
is he doing is it like color or
commentary it like when you're watching
sports and you're listening on the radio
and there's a guy telling you everything
that's happening is he doing that on the
video going much it's like play-by-play
and a lot of it too is if people are
listening that you're still able to know
exactly what's happening and for people
that are new that are better never but
watch the game it's it's interesting
because for college you need something
that you can it's easily understandable
especially if they're kind of explaining
it well so it is really it's it's kind
of cool does he ever do that when you're
playing call of duty personally like
just the two of them yeah making fun of
me because I'm not like I'm not terrible
but I'm not as good as like these pros
so he's like making fun of me basically
for two years it's not it's not that
serious I mean we still live together
I've never lived with a guy before but
you but you seem you said hey it's going
well but who knows that's what you said
well well let me ask this so you're
you're both online personalities in
different ways with obviously there's
overlap that you're talking about but I
mean that's something that you kind of
have to navigate publicly there's not
how much of it is public how much of his
private your relationship how do you
navigate that yeah I mean I think that's
that's always been something that's been
kind of hard for me cuz even I was
dating someone before and we dated for a
long time and there was not a single
photo of us online but he was a popular
youtuber he was not not this one oh I
thought that's how you're going to move
on but you made a point you guys made a
point to go oh yeah our relationship is
gonna be totally private yeah and I'm a
Christian I just wanted to try to
respect his privacy sure sure I mean I
don't think he cares if I talk about it
but it's just one of those things it's
like what is the but he wasn't a public
figure no but he just it was like I
don't really want to be in like this and
I don't want to just be associated with
that it was totally fine which was a
hard because I would go on vacations
with him and everyone's like yeah she's
she's just traveling by herself or they
would see me hanging out with girls like
she's definitely a lesbian because she's
always with these girls and like I've
had a boyfriend for three years but he
doesn't really
and he's not owning these videos so I'm
sorry and you were fine with that it was
yeah I didn't care but it made it
difficult it sounds like it was
difficult because I would sometimes what
I like even take a picture post it like
there's and there's nothing even on
Facebook at all but like nowadays yeah I
mean it's like my facebook is it's not
private but it's still pretty personal I
post family pictures and stuff like that
well I mean my impression and following
you guys both online is that you're
definitely not making any effort to hide
anything but you are it seems like
there's a calculated effort to kind of
minimize the amount of your relationship
that's out there it's like every you
know you might look at your Instagram
for a couple of weeks and you don't see
any pictures of Ryan or vice versa but
then every once in a while you'll you'll
be a picture of you and he'll I can't
wait to see this girl yeah that's always
traveling yeah no I know and but it's
funny to be even in like he'll be in my
vlogs because it's like sort of like
your daily life so it's funny because
when people won't see him for a week
because I'll be traveling too like it's
Ryan okay where's Ryan and then they
start tweeting him like no it's okay I'm
just out of town like everything's fine
don't worry but that's what they want to
do they want you know you give people an
inch of personal information they want
to take a mile
I mean listen to me giving you a hard
time on this bike I know it is and it's
it is like watching a reality show but
yet I think a lot of people I mean you
guys obviously get it like it is real
like this is a lot of the stuff that
you're seeing is is very real I mean
obviously you edit things out but it is
hard like finding that fine line because
I don't want it to be over the top but I
don't want people to just comment also
have a personal life - when you've
you've made the choice to not suddenly
have like a you know justine and ryan
channel or something like that right now
I mean there's a lot of people who do
that yeah I've actually seen a couple of
those and then they what do you do with
it after right yeah exactly
I don't know it's it is very you want me
answer the question what you do with it
after yeah delete it well I've already
I've already got my solo channel plan
for this handling breakup if it's a
couple Channel then
just dies yeah but if it was your
channel beforehand you take it over then
you take it back so if you guys were to
break that pretty clear what would you
do well it would die right would have to
start a new channel no I think there
would just be red videos and then link
videos it would be red or link Rhett
Rhett or link ah the red or link channel
never see it it's like you just you get
Tuesdays I get Thursdays yeah we can
move on from from the the relationship
thing but one last question I mean you
do you guys have to have strategic
conversations or is it kind of by feel
you have to say okay this is kind of the
line in our relationship of how we're
gonna treat this or hey the way you
Instagram that statement about our
relationship let's pull back from that
hon you know you guys you don't fight
but if you were gonna fight that would
this would be a good thing to fight over
me like hey you haven't posted any
pictures of me like well I don't get it
like it's to me like I just it's not
doing it on purpose he wants more he
wants to be more intense I'm not like
thinking that way I'm just honestly
sometimes thinking about my Instagram is
like okay I'm doing this I'm posting
this and like when we're hanging out
it's not my thought of like oh I'm gonna
have to post an Instagram with us
hanging out I don't know it's it's just
like I'm gonna have a little piece of
privacy well is it and I you know
getting to the back to the origin story
the lifecasting thing I'm sure we'll get
to that but I mean is there more of a
professional approach for you or has it
has it gotten more professional and
there being a separation like between I
guess Justine and hi Justine
yeah actually before we started
recording I was like I was this gonna be
just seniors it's gonna be I just seen
which is always I think the joke that
I've always made is like well you know
Justine like I'm actually very chill I'm
super introverted like I if I'm at home
I just want to sit at home and not be
bothered or talk to anyone and if I'm
home for a week and I don't see anyone
I'm perfectly okay with that
like that's totally fine and so people
are very surprised to actually find that
out cuz when you see me at like vidcon's
or anything I'm like always crazy and
excited but I'm just really kind of like
really chill and just want to sit in a
corner but is it is there
so the line is like that you turn the
personality up for you know anything on
camera I mean that's certainly get that
I mean I think anybody gets that but is
there a is there an actual separation of
you feel like it's kind of creating a
character
iJustine as a character and not just a
on camera amped up channel person
personality of your own personality I
think so I mean even I will struggle
with that sometimes on YouTube over like
really being I just seen right now and
I'm like oh she's so annoying I'm like
shut up so just like stop like turn the
camera off and be like okay I'm just
gonna just gonna talk be normal and not
like over-the-top crazy cuz sometimes
you do get carried away and I'll watch a
video and just delete it I'm like oh my
god you're when they comment say you're
annoying like just seeing you are
annoying so it's like I will sit there
and I will see like what these people do
see and because it is sometimes just
very characterized so yeah guys if you
say I'm annoying I'm sorry but when you
remember left that comment on any videos
no but on all the social everything that
you if you're going to Instagram you're
going to tweet or whatever there's kind
of a has it moved to more of okay this
is a professional endeavor I'm kind of
on the clock I'm not just tweeting or is
there kind of a it's still personal how
much overlap is there and is it less
than it used to be I mean I do feel like
it is a lot less because even when I'm
posting an Instagram or a tweet like I
will proofread it for like 20 minutes
I'm like did I spell everything right
did I tag everyone correctly and it
becomes so much of a chore just to send
a tweet and it's a lot of responsibility
too
and like I'm actually a good example was
I went to was in Alabama for MTV's
hangout fest and I spelled Outkast wrong
and then I didn't have any reception to
change it so I was like freaking out oh
my guys you're never gonna believe this
build I'll cast wrong and like I was
like with a see yeah I'm like I wasn't
paying attention just like typing okay
great
sent my tweet and like oh my god I'm
getting destroyed right now well you
could blame that on the autocorrect yeah
but it was not auto corrects just my own
like oops so did you follow that up with
another tweet I did okay okay yes I just
Broten capital letters in ka st great
sorry so let's get into the the origin
of that iJustine character you you say
that you were you had this photo blog at
the time what was what was that was that
the first thing that got you some
attention online and then you kind of
followed it from there maybe my first
website in sixth grade and I've actually
told this story so many times there was
his kid his name is Steve and he kicked
me and I was just I was just so upset
and this was like in-home at class could
you wear in my shins he was sitting
across from me so it would be like you
kicking me right now yeah that's called
flirting in sixth grade yeah but I think
we actually were like really hating each
other like I hated him and he hated me
and I just remember us getting our seats
moved and so I went home I was like what
do i do how do I get back at him so
obviously cyber bullying I made I hate
Steve website which I don't condone
doing this
I hate Steve I have a debt yeah so I'm
Steve calm it wasn't a dot-com because I
don't have any money or a credit card so
you can buy domains back that I don't
think was really like not something you
do I think it was like I hate Steve a
tripod dot-com or something like that so
the guy I figured out how to get
Photoshop and I learned like DreamWorks
fireworks that yeah so I would have my
Mac on a 30-day trial reboot so every 30
days I would have to format my computers
I backed up everything on discs because
I didn't know how my mom wasn't gonna
buy me the software so I would just
reinstall it all every trial every 30
days but I keep building that website
well that went in a bunch of them but
that was that was my first website I was
like this is really fun I was viewing
source on different websites to try to
like learn how to code what did Steve
say about this website um we didn't know
about it until like four years ago so
there's just like for you and yourself
it was like me and my friend Natalie I
remember me and Natalie just making this
IHC website and I was like photoshopping
his eyes red and like just I was really
happy with my work I hate you Steven
your bloodshot eyes I remember
we have scanner so I scanned his
yearbook photo in oh yeah Wow Steve yeah
no we're actually friends now okay guilt
friendship he's actually the safety
safety Steve in my Squatch watch videos
these are our safety guy yep really the
the Steve of the eye hey Steve does
tripod what is it I think my sister went
to prom with his brother yeah it's
really small town but I mean things
really started to happen with the
lifecasting that was the first thing
right yeah which is kind of crazy I'm
actually writing well I started writing
a book about that it's gonna be kind of
like telling like the stories that
happened during those times and I would
go and interview like my friends but how
did this affect you cuz they're even des
she was like it's either me or the
camera and she moved out so oh wow okay
so you guys were roommates so how did it
how did it start
so I mean I was still doing like all the
sort of the river the river and the
YouTube stuff and still posting videos
and I was working before that I was
doing like freelance and I loved like
video production and graphic design so I
basically started making YouTube videos
so that people would know that I knew
how to edit and was more just promoting
myself so that I could get jobs oh God
before that I was actually working at a
chiropractor when you crack him back sir
no I was their video production yeah and
for that I was I worked at a graphic
design house and this chiropractor came
into the this.get with a graphic design
place and like ordered some brochures or
something and he was like hey do you
know anybody that was at an edit video
oh oh this is great like I know how to
edit he's like okay do you want to come
work for me I'll double your salary do
you know how to use avid I said no I
don't know how to use that I'm thinking
myself but I'm like yeah I know how to
use avid this is great so I like quit my
job there what and worked at this
chiropractor the next week taught myself
a typewriter who had an avid sweet who
is this go to avid sweets nonetheless
yeah I'm pretty sure he's not in
business anymore and I think there's
several lawsuits out against him for a
lot of different things but either
a chiropractor who has to avid sweets is
uh yeah there's a label for that there's
a lot of things that we're going
frontman for something well so yeah
meeting a company that they would like
make commercials for different
chiropractors so that's what I was
editing we've done that we made
commercials for practice before little
inappropriate slightly but yeah and then
I think some of the first videos I
started making was in the chiropractor's
office like the oatmeal video was in the
chiropractor off okay so that's now the
earliest video you can see on your
YouTube channel is your chiropractor
office open ill eating video edited on
avid so so you were making like comedic
videos and just kind of putting them out
there but and then what the lifecasting
thing was just that kind of happened in
parallel kind of I quit the chiropractor
job and I mean it was it was great but I
was like this is terrible like I'm
working 80 some hours a week slaving
over a chiropractor stuff like we had to
be there way did you like he's training
things and all this weird stuff like
over the weekends but I was like a
really fast editor so in the time that
it took me to edit what a normal person
would edit I would be like editing on my
laptop in Final Cut like all these other
videos but after I quit there I met this
guy Justin in San Francisco of Justin TV
what were you in San Francisco for
Macworld
so you went as an attendee or you were
vlogging I went out with um there was
this podcast called macbreak so I'm out
there with them and did some like sort
of hosting stuff and I saw the dude with
like a camera on his head I was like oh
my god this guy's really cool he was but
he turned out to be actually really cool
and they were starting this company
called justin TV which was a live
streaming platform and he's like yeah in
the next week I'm gonna be
live-streaming my entire life for the
next however long this is amazing and
then he did and he did it for a while
and then they were
opening up their platform to other
people and he's like do you want to be
the first or the second person to
livestream so it worked out great
Justin Justine I mean yeah just yet I
mean didn't even think that was my name
they just thought I was an actress like
know my name I really enjoy doing this
stuff so I did that for six months so
you literally had a camera on your head
like a headlamp camera type thing like a
logitech webcam with a light on it like
that lets people know that it's
recording and you connected to the
Internet via like a satellite connection
that's when Sprint had unlimited access
unlike their a video cards so I think
that me and Justin single-handedly
stopped that from ever happening so this
was this was mobile this wasn't just
like while you're home this was at all
times and maybe the connection was a
little slow from time to time but
everything yeah I mean not everything
let's get to crazy you know so where
would you put the camera when you use
the bathroom I would make it look at a
picture of Steve Jobs which you like had
outside of the restroom no I had a
framed photo of him on my desk was this
branding or was this until my friend
actually got me that for my birthday one
year okay thank you go so that it's
brilliant branding I'm not stalking you
for it was just on my desk so I would
always like flip it over I put a note
card like be right back going to
bathroom or whatever like doing
something I don't want you to see yeah
I'm doing some six months and the only
breaks were bathroom breaks and when you
were sleeping where was it um it was
just sitting on my desk watching me
sleep creepy you know I remember I'd
always play a I always play tool like
the band tool I would sleep to that so
everybody would get a nice tool
soundtrack every night's so so you
didn't earn that you didn't mute it no
if you talked in your sleep they would
they couldn't hear it over because it
was it was a wide shot it wasn't like a
shot of like your mouth in your eyes and
your nose it was a very wide shot yeah
but I mean I would sleep in so they
would like think I was dead when I
wasn't waking up they said they were
like it's like calling my mom who I
think she's not okay
and what did okay so you already hinted
at the fact that Desiree had a problem
with this and and said I'm out yeah but
what about what what went into the
decision did you talk to your parents
about it they're like nah I don't even
remember how it all came about I was
like oh this is cool all right I'll do
it I don't know why I even ever agreed
but it was it was still kind of fun you
got paid to do it right no originally no
I didn't which was crazy because they
was watching me like run a business
essentially like I would be taking I
would take it into meetings with me and
I would mute it because I was still
doing like graphic design and web design
and video stuff so I would take it to a
coffee shop and it would watch me like
edit what do you tell people and stuff I
mean it wasn't that obvious cuz if I was
at a coffee shop it just looked like I
had just a hat just sitting there
I didn't realize as a web cam on it and
you were filming that yeah it's not as
wrong when you're not getting paid for
it yeah I mean it wasn't on my head like
it was just like I would take it off my
head and just sit on the the desk
so it would be looking at me so yeah it
wasn't a very you just did it because it
seemed cool I mean what the concerns of
like the privacy and quality of life
these are things that I don't even think
about it I was just like this is this is
this is a cool thing and it that's when
I first started doing like the video and
editing and it was just it was really
fun so it's like oh this is great I
don't have to edit anything it's just
live yeah so for six months you
by-and-large loved doing it or how far
in were you like oh I don't it started
hitting around like the three month
point but then I was like so invested it
was like it was like an abusive
relationship really love this oh my god
I hate it like I would sometimes that's
what the hell am i doing like I don't
even to this day sometimes when I think
about like doing a livestream like I
just get anxiety thinking of like back
in the day like just doing that non-stop
was there a low point yeah got a few low
points right just like unplug and just
start crying because I mean you're it's
such an emotional overload of people
constantly judging you I mean just
non-stop all day long just having
something to say about you
and you can look at this chat you know
at all times yeah at all times I really
I think that I'm this or I'm doing this
or whatever and I'd have to be so
careful like if I make sure I'd wear
like a shirt that was like pulled up at
all times like if I wore a tank top I
have to be so careful because you never
know because if something happens live
like it's live it's there forever
and something that I did find it's
something like that happened no
thankfully I don't know how it didn't in
six months but one thing I did learn is
that there are sneeze people there are
people that have sneeze fetishes what do
they say when you sneeze do it again
they love it like they love it and
there's like compilations still to this
day on YouTube just all my justin.tv
sneezes really yep whatever it takes but
you're okay with it I mean you're not
you know it's not like you're creeped
out by the sneeze fetish people it's
kind of kind of every time I sneeze that
that's what I think of so it's kind of
there I should have recorded that for
those guys and the feet people lots of
feet people oh yeah yeah because they
would sit around sooner or later they'd
see your feet and there it is it's it's
on the feet wiki I'm sure you guys have
one too you just probably haven't looked
at them but you would turn it off and
break down crying there was definitely
some points yeah and you lost a roommate
over it I did yeah
cuz I made definitely made a conscious
decision I was like this is what I'm
doing like I'm gonna do this thing and
she just wasn't really into it I mean
we're so good friends like I love her
and she still is like I can't believe
you're still doing all this crazy stuff
right I mean so it you did the life
casting thing and that stopped after six
months was it during that that time that
you started having some of those initial
YouTube videos breakout was that all the
same year actually at the same time was
one the iPhone bill okay 300-page yeah
so what was kind of crazy as that was
all happening that was all still being
life casted so it would the camera would
come with me to like like two satellite
interviews that would go to wherever
like Australia and stuff like that so it
was kind of it was a really crucial time
because it all happened sort of right
there and then it was all life casted
and how big did the the iPhone bill go
it was three new pages so and how big
did a video got me in turn actually a
good question I think there's only like
three or four million views on YouTube
but then I remember on Yahoo it had so
many more and then MySpace that had so
many because it was just featured
everywhere all of those other sites had
actually tons of views and even on River
River money I was so sad when Reverend I
had no idea because I would have
downloaded all my old videos
oh they kept sending warnings about that
really they were like we're shutting
down download your videos are you
serious yeah we downloaded all ours no
no we didn't in four V's that remember
really way back I I guess I do yeah I
did not get the email maybe I'm just bad
at email but I'm very sad about it so
you were getting all this press for this
huge iPhone bill did you cry in that
video right no she cried the Steve Jobs
right no I didn't cry in the iPhone bill
did cry about Steve Jobs which with that
video good choice by the way if you're
gonna only cry on one yeah but the thing
is I posted that on my iPhone channel
which is like honestly I only wanted
that video to be seen no more than
15,000 times to like my hardcore fans
that know how much Steve Jobs meant to
me so it was more just like a reaction
like that was honestly real I turned on
the camera I was like I'm doing this and
posted it and then I was like oh great
front page of Reddit for just seemed
farting while crying about Steve Jobs
I'm like oh my god are you kidding me
how they find this you farted well no I
didn't I had on like rubber boots so I
was it was like scooting on this show I
don't remember that so that was that was
the meme that was going around okay and
then I'm like crying I'm not farting you
it's rubber boots so yeah okay it was
fun so I mean it's widely recognized
that you're not just one of the first
women but one of the first people who
had this my life is out there I am a
vlogger like when people think of
vlogger like you know we talked about
this
you still can't type vlogger into your
word processing application and it it
won't accept it it still doesn't see it
as a word even in 2014 which is just
[ __ ] melaka it makes it are flogging
but before anybody was really
understanding what that word was and
they were still saying v logging yeah
you were doing it yeah it was weird cuz
it wasn't I wasn't thinking that I was
doing that like I mean I was blogging at
the time so that was just for me an
easier way to say something is I didn't
I wasn't like I call sis so much easier
if I just talked about it instead of
writing it and the thing then is there
wasn't mobile phones so it wasn't as
easily to be accessible as it is now I
mean now you're watching videos on the
go in the car probably shouldn't be if
you're having and watching YouTube
videos well you know we had we had jenna
Marbles on on the here biscuit a while
back and she mentioned you as her
inspiration yeah once she decided to
start doing yes she was like I did I
want to do what she's doing I've watched
a lot of iJustine videos to figure out a
game plan basically I mean do you feel
like an online matriarch I mean I think
this whole table right here I mean this
is AG o UT the original youtubers I mean
it is and like I mean like Phil and like
that whole like crew of people I mean
it's it's so crazy that I mean I don't
even know why originally we were doing
it I mean I was just doing it for fun
like I really loved editing I still love
editing I love making people laugh and
just having fun and I don't know there's
just an audience out there for
everything which is so cool that now
people are doing that the only thing now
as a lot of people are just doing it
because they want to be like a youtuber
I guess so it's so different because we
were just doing it because we really I
don't know we're just having fun yeah
it's there it's interesting that you
know that first in second and sort of
you know those first couple of waves of
of online entertainers we all did it
because it was just this new and
exciting thing and it's I mean that
can't happen again it's gonna happen
with some other medium right but it
can't happen again with this it's pretty
it's pretty cool to think about that is
that we literally
were doing it for just to see what would
happen
yeah right yeah and it's interesting
gets I've kind of seen that happen with
vine like a lot of these vine kids like
it's so crazy cuz they were doing the
same thing just else is cool I can make
a really cool video in six seconds so
it's kind of cool to see sort of that
same community like happen over there on
another platform and I got to meet
actually at recently a couple of them
like wow you guys are so cool this is
awesome like it's a whole another thing
it was like it was been so long since
I've felt like that feeling of like the
original youtubers and like I can see it
with them and I'm like this is awesome
so it was really exciting yeah I mean
you say eight years ago that was that
was you on with streaming and with
YouTube and it's beginning phase and but
you know so now fast-forward to the
present time and there's there's a
struggle to maintain relevance I know
for us you know it's it's true of all
entertainment but I feel like everything
is so accelerated on YouTube and online
that there's so many more people coming
in a lot of people who say okay now I
can make a living at this kind of thing
there's so it's competition on one hand
but it's being around this long there's
a challenge to continuing to rise to the
top yeah and I think that's hard and
it's it's funny about like the vine like
so it took us I mean what this is like
eight years later so for them I mean
that happened in less than a year so
it's like crazy just like that platform
just rise up and all of these new people
just kind of pop up out of nowhere and
then even for them it's interesting cuz
the transition doesn't transition that
well over to YouTube it's like two
completely separate sure different
audiences but how how is it for you at
this point with everything that's
happening on YouTube and the landscape
here and the difficulty it is to to keep
getting views maybe the views that you
could get before you know how it how do
you interact with that what's the
strategy is it okay you know there's a
hosting component to what you do now
that's independent of your YouTube
channel is you know is that is there a
struggle there is there a frustration
the frustration comes from knowing that
I'm posting stuff and knowing that their
subscribers there that will never see it
and why I matter no is that a YouTube
thing is that what it's like people
still everyday like when are you posting
a new video I'm like I've posted like 20
this week
sure eyes not see any of those anywhere
so I think that's the hard part is just
knowing that like you've worked so hard
to get this audience and you don't have
access to them I think that's the
struggle it's like I mean I know I'm
posting stuff and like no one is why are
you guys not seeing it and I even talked
to the audience directly I'm like why
did you guys not see this and I know
there's another crazy thing because I
will post something on Facebook and I
will see like the impressions of that
post which nowhere near will reflect
anything on YouTube so microd anybody to
watch it like what does that mean mm-hmm
because and then if I post something
just directly on Facebook I can actually
see how many views that gets I don't
know something's going on there's a
conspiracy guys need to get to the
bottom of it I'm wondering how your
YouTube channel plays into it the
hosting gigs all the opportunities that
you take and projects that you're
launching it aren't on your channel is
there a division of strategies that's
not and YouTube is just a part of it
yeah I mean YouTube will always be a
part of it and I think just creating
content and sometimes I forget what my
audience likes like they love iPhones
they love technology and sometimes I'm
like off doing something else that's
crazy Michael I forgot like they don't
really that's not something that they're
into but it's fun to be able to share
sort of those different things so when I
make a video talking about like my
iPhone or technology like those do so
much better because that's that's really
what my audience wants to see so
sometimes I forget about that too and so
I lose sight of stuff that they
originally started subscribing for so I
think that's something that I have to
keep in mind too because I might be
traveling and I want to post like travel
vlogs but that's not really not
everybody's into that I think just
trying to find out what they like what
they want and just posting consistently
which has always been a problem for me
so I'm like I don't have time to post so
I'm sorry you're not gonna get a video
now I mean how do you navigate it you
developed a standard with your brand
there's certain things you're not going
to do
but you know is there this is there a
temptation that okay if I'm in why don't
why don't I be in my bikini and a
thumbnail some more always been a that's
I would imagine that that's something
that you know if it gets if that gets
traction there's a decision to be made
all along the way thing is like I look
at my analytics too it's like they're
mostly girls so I mean maybe they want
to seem in my bikini but like whatever
but that's cool but my bikini rule is
only when I'm on vacation which is a
quite a bit yeah quite a bit sometimes
you know well it has the has the fact
that YouTube is is frustrating for lots
of different reasons right I mean
YouTube audience can be very fickle they
can get tired of certain things they
there can be technical glitches that
you're kind of talking about there's all
kinds of frustrations involved with it
and it also just you know one year is a
decade you know it so in having almost
done it for a decade you've like lived a
several lifetimes online right but
they're all those frustrating
frustrations involved related to YouTube
but you've you've got so much traction
in a lot of other places right I mean
like I said you know you're hosting you
all kinds of things and you're doing
lots of TV opportunities how is that
part of your career going and are you
hoping to continue to kind of push in
that direction and do the frustrations
on YouTube kind of serve as a driving
force to kind of move you know more into
that kind of thing I think so and then
I've been doing it for so long so I'm
like okay like what do I do next which
is why I was like I really want to do
this book which originally the book kind
of all came about more as like a joke
cuz I kept telling the audience it's
like I'll just save it for the book save
it for the book and then he started like
pitching TV shows and like movie type
things about like that's six months of
the live streaming to production
companies and studios wow this is great
like we love this idea and then I was
like wait let's just stop all of this
I'm just gonna write the book so I have
sort of that thing that's like okay
here's the stories I have these these
are mine this is what I want it to be
about so I just kind of wanted it to go
back to that
and just have those stories and then
either kind of ask the audience like
what do you guys want me to do with this
do you want me to turn it into a TV show
do you want it to be a movie like what
do you guys want because honestly like
having them make the decisions it's kind
of what I've always done and then ways
have such really good ideas like when I
need a video idea I mean they're on it
them like you guys are so great
all these little mini producers so
what's the book gonna be called I just
recently googled how to write a book so
I'm probably yeah what depends on what
kind of book you're writing I guess but
we'll see
so you haven't you haven't put pen to
paper yet so to speak um I've actually
cuz so I started doing like the draw my
life so okay young so I sort of have a
nice little outline but then I'm gonna
go kind of crowdsource maybe dig up some
ex-boyfriends and have them write some
things for me josh is gonna josh is
gonna have a chapter and Steve I mean
this ghost girl went back to Steve so
it's not that she didn't want to talk
about him and said she didn't want to
talk about him before they're in her
book I understand now
no the problem wasn't getting hot in
here no the perhaps I honestly don't
remember so many things like it's awful
like I'm actually looking forward to
doing this like I want to make it'll
just be like on Facebook like alright to
all of my actual friends how did we meet
what were some fun things that we did
did we date did I hurt you do you hate
me like I want to know everything what
you do realize that when you access a
memory you actually change it really
every time you access a memory you
change it like physically well the way
it's arranged in your brain so be
careful what you remember well at least
somebody else remembers that do you have
a sense that when you ask your friends
have I how have I hurt you however that
that's what you're gonna get back that
you've you've hurt people and that
you've alienated people I definitely
think there's some people out there that
may feel that way so I'm just wondering
like how
honest would they like to be about it
and because actually this is really fine
I did a reddit AMA which probably won't
ever do again cuz retton's none like me
oh really
no but it went really well at first but
then there was somebody on there that
kept saying like I know you from like
back in the day or and and he was saying
things I was like oh my god this person
does know me and they're like saying
like that I hurt them and they do are
you hurt you hurt them and we're like
emotional I do this like what did I do
like I don't I didn't mean to do that
so I just I just want to know those
things cuz I don't know kind of it's
kind of fascinating and I think if
there's good stories in there that's
stuff that I would like to include wow
so this so the way people have
remembered your life is going to be a
major element in this yeah and that and
like how I've affected a bunch of like
my audience I mean I know there's been
so many kids I think that not just me
but like youtubers in general have
really changed their lives people have
said they've they've watched us in like
hospital rooms and we've got them
through such tough times so I really
want to kind of get those stories and
just I mean I went to school for graphic
design and video production so I do have
that background but I've always never
known what I wanted to do I've never
really planned anything and I want to
just let people know that like if you
have an idea if you want to do something
like if you want to do it bad enough
like you can do it like I'm writing a
book I don't know how to write a book
I'll figure it out I googled it that's
my first step so I just think if there's
something that you want to do you can
you can figure it out and if not then
you don't want to do it bad enough well
listen I look forward to reading it so
get to writing it you'll do an audio
version too so if you want us to write a
little just a little paragraph about
that podcast that we don't remember very
well I don't remember either yes you
know oh no you guys I mean the og I mean
I was like I just remember finding rhett
and Link they're so funny like and I
kept telling dozen like look we can be
like them we can do this too and there's
other two radio DJs in Pittsburgh Mikey
and Big Bob who were also like my
inspiration I kept telling him like look
this give us we could do this is a be
really [ __ ] Big Bob yes oh we have
better names than Mikey and Big Bob yeah
I gotta say that's pretty good oh well
good Bob is big I could be bigger
Alabang he's not his first name no he's
just he's just a big dude Oh names Bob
no they're so funny but it was like I
like I really wanted like that duo like
I think that's what I want like that'd
be so fun and then no one ever could
hold on along for the ride so that life
cassie is quite a commitment yeah right
yes yeah well listen before you start
writing the book you'd have to write on
our table yeah consider that a start
it's much easier than writing a book you
don't have to Google how to do this well
there it was our ear biscuit with
Justine is Eric you know I I think it's
cool to be able to reconnect with
Justine after I mean she was one of the
first people that we befriended on the
internet who was trying to do the same
thing we were doing I mean that was
almost 10 years ago man so it's cool to
sit down and reconnect and it's like
full circle well we were in a basement
in Lillington North Carolina and the
first time that we talked to her and we
were on that podcast she was somewhere
outside of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
we nobody knew what we were trying to do
nobody knew where this was what was
gonna go no one knew if there was any
more traction with the river than there
was with YouTube I mean really that's
that's that was a state of things right
yeah and here we are this many years
later don't know anything now either we
still don't know anything but I do know
a couple things
hey YouTube is better than river youtube
turn delete be well just by virtue of it
existing YouTube turned out to be a
safer bet than revver
and you know she's out here in Los
Angeles we're out here in Los Angeles
in some weird way in the way that the
industry change and the way that online
entertainment became what it is
we brought us all out here it's cool to
connect I'll tell you something else I
want to go to that hot spring in Iceland
well every time you know I'll drop my
phone in there if that's what it takes
you go I don't know what you were gonna
drop I'll drop my drawers and get in
there that's what you're gonna say it's
not that kind of Hot Springs I drop a
phone in there
what it takes I do think we should we
should visit more exotic spots and make
videos there and post them on Justine's
channel no she won't
I don't think she's on our Channel I
mean we should do that I mean every time
I look at her Instagram she's on in
another tropical location and I'm like
wow you know when we gonna do that
what happened to us I can't answer that
question right I don't know when we're
gonna do that when we gonna get around
to it but if there's I do like the idea
of hot springs with my last experience
in a hot spring which was shared on GMM
required being totally naked with some
really old senior citizen men so it just
I mean that was that didn't happen in
Justine's blog vlog she's got a
different thing let me say the water
wasn't cloudy like it was in that Blue
Lagoon in Iceland Iceland I like it it
was pretty transparent as far as I
remember
so tweet it justine let her know that
you appreciated her ear biscuit here you
know we put her on the spot about a
couple of things and so i appreciate her
being a good sport about that and you
know you can also tweet at us and tell
us that we're good sports to you but
what you could do is if you're a fan of
your biscuits and you want to continue
to hear this show every single week you
can leave us a comment or a review on
itunes that helps a lot leave us a
comment on Soundcloud let us know what
you think about these biscuits for your
ears and certainly you can hear from us
next week with another biscuit of ear
[Music]
[Music]